WOULD YOUR HOUSE STILL BE YOUR
THAT IS THE LEFT'S PLAN FOR
AMERICA AND FINALLY THEY ARE
SAYING IT OUT LOUD.
WE ARE GOING TO PAUSE AND BRING
YOU TO A NEWS CONFERENCE
UNDERWAY.
OFFICIALS IN MARYLAND BRIEFING
NOTIFYING THE NEXT OF KIN.
WE HAVE FIVE CONFIRMED FATAL'S
AND TWO INJURIES.
THE INJURIES TO MY UNDERSTANDING
ARE SUPERFICIAL, POSSIBLY FROM
GLASS FROM THE SHOTGUN BLAST.
WE ARE WORKING ON NOW SECURING
HIS RESIDENCE.
WE ARE IN THE PROCESS OF
SECURING THAT RESIDENCE AND
PREPARING FOR SEARCH WARRANTS.
SO THIS IS THE NEXT PHASE OF
THIS SCENE, AND THAT IS THE
INVESTIGATIVE PHASE.
THIS IS THE PART THAT TAKES THE
MOST TIME, AS I WOULD ASSUME
MANY OF YOU HAVE ALREADY HEARD
FROM MANY OTHER POLICE AGENCIES
IN THE STATE OF MARYLAND AND
ACROSS THE COUNTRY, THE
INVESTIGATIVE PROCESS IS VERY
DIFFICULT.
WE MUST BE THOROUGH AND THAT IS
WHY YOU WILL NOT GET THE
INFORMATION FROM SOCIAL MEDIA OR
FROM US UNLESS IT HAS BEEN
CONFIRMED.
WE HAVE ALLOWED OUR
INVESTIGATORS TO DO THEIR JOB
AND THEY ARE THERE NOW, AND WE
ARE GOING TO CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
YOU WITH INFORMATION.
I WANT TO SHARE SOMETHING WITH
YOU THAT I THINK IS IMPORTANT.
WE MENTIONED BEFORE ABOUT THE
IMPROVISED EXPLOSIVE DEVICE.
THAT IS NOT AN IED, IT WAS
ACTUALLY CANISTERS OF SMOKE
GRENADES THAT HE USED INSIDE OF
THE BUILDING WHEN HE ENTERED THE
ESTABLISHMENT.
SO THIS PERSON WAS PREPARED
TODAY TO COME IN.
THIS PERSON WAS PREPARED TO
AND, AS I STATED BEFORE THE
INVESTIGATIVE PART OF THIS IS
GOING TO BE THOROUGH AND IT'S
GOING TO TAKE SOME TIME.
AS YOU CAN SEE BEHIND US, WE
OPENED UP THAT ROAD.
WE THOUGHT THAT WE MAY NEED TO
SECURE THAT ROADWAY FOR A LONG
PERIOD OF TIME, AND AS WE GET
FURTHER INTO THE INVESTIGATION,
WE REALIZE THAT WE DON'T NEED
THAT ROADWAY.
THE BUILDING, 888 THAT SKATE
WILL BE SECURED FOR SOME TIME.
I DO NOT HAVE A TIME FRAME ON
THAT YET.
WE WILL BE INSIDE OF THERE FOR
QUITE A BIT, UNTIL THIS
INVESTIGATION IS COMPLETE.
WHEN I HAVE MORE CONFIRMED
INFORMATION, I WILL SHARE THAT
CONFIRMED INFORMATION WITH YOU.
>> EXACTLY WHAT WAS HIS BEEF
WITH THIS NEWSPAPER?
>> THAT'S WHAT WE ARE
INVESTIGATING NOW.
>> IT'S ALREADY BEEN REPORTED HE
HAS A HISTORY WITH THE NEWSPAPER
YEARS AGO.
>> THAT'S WHAT WE ARE HEARING
BUT WE NEED THE INVESTIGATORS TO
CONFIRM THAT.
>> IS HE LIVING IN AN ANNAPOLIS
>> NO, I CAN'T SHARE THAT WITH
YOU.
THAT'S THE FIRST TIME I'VE HEARD
HE IS AT OUR CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION DIVISION.
OUR DETECTIVES ARE DOWN THERE
WITH HIM AND I HAVE NOT
INTERRUPTED HIM TO ASK IF HE'S
>> THE ONLY CONNECTION THAT I
CAN TELL YOU ABOUT RIGHT NOW IS
POSSIBLY THROUGH SOCIAL MEDIA.
I HAVE NO OTHER CONFIRMATION.
>> [INDISTINCT QUESTION]
>> WE ARE STILL LOOKING INTO
THAT.
I CANNOT CONFIRM WHETHER OR NOT
OUR DEPARTMENT HAS COME INTO
CONTACT WITH HIM AND WE WILL
HAVE THAT AT A LATER TIME AS
WELL.
>> HAVE YOU HAD ANY COMMENTS
FROM ANY FAMILY MEMBERS?
>> CAN YOU TELL US IF HE IS A
RESIDENT OF MARYLAND OR IF HE
CAME FROM OUTSIDE?
>> HE'S A RESIDENT OF MARYLAND.
INVESTIGATION.
YOU JUST TARGETED THE BUSINESS
IN GENERAL.
>> CAN YOU TELL US WHERE IN
MARYLAND?
>> NO.
>> WHEN WILL YOU CONFIRM HIS
SHOTGUN?
WAS IT A SPORTING SHOTGUN OR
WHERE THE SMOKE GRENADES
>> I DON'T HAVE THAT
INFORMATION.
>> WERE ALL THE PEOPLE SHOT IN
THE NEWSPAPER OFFICE?
>> DEPUTY CHIEF, THERE'S TALK
ABOUT THE GOVERNMENT TRYING TO
HIDE HIS IDENTITY IN CERTAIN
WAYS, MAYBE WITH HIS
FINGERPRINTS BURNED OFF AND
>> THAT'S A FIRST TIME I'VE
HEARD FACIAL RECOGNITION AND THE
FIRST TIME I'VE HEARD
FINGERPRINTS, NO VERIFICATION OF
RECORD?
>> I CAN'T CONFIRM THAT.
>> [INDISTINCT QUESTION]
>> WE KNOW THERE WERE THREATS
THE THREATS WERE SENT OVER
SOCIAL MEDIA AND WE ARE TRYING
TO CONFIRM WHAT ACCOUNT THAT WAS
AND TRYING TO CONFIRM WHO
ACTUALLY SENT THEM.
>> >> WE WILL CONTINUE TO MONIT